[Music]
in crazy cou CEO CEO news submitted by
green chairs interesting beauty fans are
in a panic after the CEO of a cult brand
announces an abrupt company shutdown
code being brand or coke call C ult yeah
like the whole ball team following him
uses his brand would you like to name
the brand well she uses the brand brand
Amway something called the ordinary yeah
Kim says like it's on Titans and target
everywhere it's like being friendly a
[ __ ] it's being friendly cruelty-free so
they've been very popular because it's
super affordable great products all this
stuff right buster their CEO named
Brandon oh you got something to say to
us buddy uh he'd better be a great CEO
Jamie uses his product so please Brandon
and this is the ordinary this uh why is
he trying to [ __ ] the air with his eyes
that's the beauty world man that's the
beauty world what wait what is that
oh my make this oxygen come beauty [ __ ]
you put it on your body look at
something really bright so it's kind of
like a oil or something something okay
yeah I'll spit on your face for [ __ ]
$10 girl yeah
I'll [ __ ] make a million brand des
iam this brand is iam su the tagline is
called the abnormal beauty company and
so Estee Lauder is also a minor
shareholder in this company so like the
whole big thing is that brandon has been
using desi owns company Instagram to
insult fans cancel partnerships top
trash about competing brands and like
just using this entire Instagram page as
like a intercompany telling people like
alright we will no longer use plastic so
make sure so and so make sure that this
person knows that we're no longer gonna
be ordering from that person like some
intercompany talk he's just very
transparent
so then people are very concerned for
his mental health but also they're not
sure if this is a marketing ploy because
it's everyone's been like super locked
in on Instagram right he posts a picture
of his [ __ ] sexy ass eyes just
looking off into space and in the comics
he's like you know we're gonna go no
plastic so make sure Stacy the
data-entry [ __ ] stops using those
straws and [ __ ] because it's gonna make
us look bad pretty much like [ __ ] like
that the captions do not match funny I
like that
since January of this year Brandon
posted a video announcing that he will
be handling all social media by himself
and since then mayhem mayhem so let me
show you that one video just so you
could get like a little taste of what
he's gonna make me come yeah yeah I've
decided to drop my title I'm no longer
called CEO and called worker at this am
responsible people do you like those
parents that don't want a parent but
they want to be our brother the windup
will record that [ __ ] on a [ __ ] Nokia
brick like what the [ __ ] got you hello
rich like you also like posted a video
saying like yeah like I'm gonna be doing
it and then have you been making
headlines left and right for all these
scandals and because of this Instagram
account so that was in January 24th
January 29th he made a post claiming
that somebody attempted to hack Jesse on
Instagram and so he closed access to all
social media except for himself and one
other person claiming that it could be
past employees or competitors or someone
that just doesn't like them and it's
just so like he jumped to the gun and it
was all because he got this one email
saying that like did you forget your
password and just because that one email
he just blew it up and saying like we're
trying like someone's trying to hack
into this like he's just so like
dramatic so dramatic change my
let's see what he did this it's it's
almost like a 12 year old girl became a
CEO yes so then he makes a video in fact
on February 1st he makes a video like
[ __ ] the video I just showed you guys
about here not good pepper removing the
CEO from his name and then so on
February 4th he releases a video of a
garbage floating in a river and his
caption was saying thank you severed
ties from its packaging provider because
of the use of plastics and then he ends
up like offering him to sponsor him in
Canada where he lives and that he was
like hey he could bring your whole
family you can work for my company
because I will no longer be buying your
plastic products like that's the lunar
alright so I know you're gonna be out of
the job ok relocate I'm not gonna be
doing business with you anymore Apple
thinks he's the only customer he's so
insecure man like Cooper he's like I
don't want you to dislike me so you can
come work with me okay we're still
friends yeah Oh his whole thing is about
like in a loving way and like in a
positive Oh what if you put him on black
like that's like me walking into a
liquor store like hey man I quit
drinking but if you want a job with JK
you could always come to me that's what
he's doing he's putting it on his
Instagram that's super popular not even
his Instagram versus the company no
that's that new way dude it's like a
pseudo positivity dude yeah super like
that like it's like a back fat kind of
compliment yeah it's like this whole
fake positive energy [ __ ] dude it's like
you know what if you're a positive
person you just positive dude people
will feed off that [ __ ] you ain't gotta
keep saying it yeah man yo man bless sup
bro I call it lotion hands dude lotion
hand ashy ass hands with y'all real talk
though bro yeah Real Talk man you what
I'm gonna do now is lotion up my whole
body when I talk to people
yeah real top raw I just wanna say bro I
really like you a lot and also oh [ __ ]
on your face yep oh like this lotion
hands [ __ ] ridiculous man I should do
that buy it right when I install people
like I mean this in the most positive
way possible but [ __ ] you I hope you
[ __ ] die positivity
bless bro I hope the best for you you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] on that same
daily you posted about the garbage he
posted a picture of what appears to be a
dead sheep and that's in order to
protest animal rights
queue and then the comments started
coming in saying like hey this is like
Brandon's personal page and Alex is not
about the company like these are very
off-putting posts like there's a little
too much transparent see here like it's
like good too much like there's enough
where you can just got to clean our
bathrooms last Thursday yeah it like
that forgot their keys at that on this
desk anybody would take a big share of
the keys and that's kind of funny damn I
want to follow this guy so he ends up
saying On February 5th that's his
instace free is like you know he's
addressing it cuz he's been posting a
whole bunch of [ __ ] and so he promises
to build the social content team to
curate it better and then he also
promised to donate two hundred thousand
dollars to charities couples gonna give
five other people just like him yeah why
does he need a donate cuz he no one's
saying anything about that this fool is
like a dictator in but like in a beauty
world or some [ __ ] like he thinks what
he does matters it's so funny he's like
I gotta [ __ ] change I'm a [ __ ]
examples to all these people that look
up to me
three former employees anonymously go on
record about Brandon's they can't say
anything about poor leadership because
he stopped stepped down as a leader he
doesn't even want to be a leader yeah is
that his title yeah he's like we're all
workers this title no he's still running
the company so he'll think deeply yeah
I'm saying they were saying like you
know the products are amazing they're on
point but this fool is just [ __ ]
bonkers he's just like
what they wrote is this whole company is
a sham the only good thing about it is
its products apart from that everything
about management is ridiculous from the
way they handle interviews to blame and
founded nepotism the way they run the
company is and on every account people
get promoted way too fast and no
experience and no idea what they're
doing and it shows in the poor way they
handle everything the company grew too
fast for them to know
do with it and they still don't know
what to do with it and don't seem to be
trying to figure it out
sounds like a company I would run just
kale it sounds like everyone's first
company that's what happens everyone's
first startup but when you blow up too
damn big and too damn hard this is what
happens so you can't handle Fame and
exactly with that too they were also
saying that Hugh just yells at employees
all the time and thank-yous not a good
leader and they were saying that the
their Glassdoor reviews of decime they
found that 32 out of its 32 reviews 14
were positive and 18 were just terrible
at least the products are [ __ ] dope
and they're super affordable like that's
the way they grew so fast because I they
don't chart like for example this other
company was charging let's say like 72
dollars for this one serum thing but
they were charging like 15 bucks like
that's how crazy different it is there
were these series of emails that Brandon
sent to his employees partners lawyers
and investors claiming that he's done
with the company this happened in April
and he's like I'm done with this him and
everything no need to discuss music I
love you I'm going home in a short weird
video and why this will actin like a
YouTube lifestyle vlogger and no dude
he's gonna make like I quit YouTube
video and [ __ ] so then that's when now
good hang out with Jake Paul right now
excuse me that was in April and then
like everything's been fine or whatever
up until now but then now he posted my
back [ __ ] like he had been back but
now the thing like we're done the
company that like it's a better phone or
no hi everyone I'm Brandon true accent
founder of this year this is the final
post of the CM will shut down all
operations until further notice we got
two months please take me seriously book
this is Justin regional store this is
Brandon were social that really safe the
three of us plus protein
and maybe a couple of others are only
the original together I am NOT able to
control the sentencing of the most
beautiful people just mentioned just in
that Brandon riad and if they're
involved but almost everyone at the same
has been involved in a major criminal
activity which includes financial crimes
at much other well you have no idea what
a soldier I've been for more than 13
years I've been made fun of as a porn
actor for 13 years it's all ending now
though [ __ ] is going on so unstable dude
way people make fun of me they say I'm a
porn is like a delight Kanye Kanye
behavior he looks like he's [ __ ] them
right and then in the caption he has
this like laundry list of like calling
people out like for example hi it's the
hotels yeah yeah the hotels almost out
of it yes they Lauder
hmm and then coat down all the way to he
ends up tagging like Richard Branson and
Donald Trump Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg
mr. Baggot George Clooney Brad Pitt Ben
Affleck like oh yeah but before all this
- there was this other like episode
[Laughter]
Winnie the Pooh [ __ ] bees our cuts
ever yeah there is another random s
episode where he was and like he was in
London and they were he was just running
away from somebody and saying like I'm
help guys help Colin I'm on one color
one they have my luggage like please
like all this stuff in the ended up
commenting like sir I'm the bellboy I'm
taking it to your room you asked me to
do that
yeah I'm commenting this like everyone
please contact the airport security
help me 901 901 they have my luggage
call police this is real like
awesome and then now if you go on that
Instagram page like there's a still
calling wild let's hook on wild like you
posted bees weird ass like what that
golem and chump and he posted it twice
that at real Donald Trump good mid
evening from I'm so curious what is the
criminal activity they were all involved
in that he is at meeting to he's like I
don't know they're sentencing and then
another criminal activity dude yeah big
mean doing they're being mean about the
money was arrested for being a bets I
didn't do another oh oh his ex co-ceo
co-ceo ex co-ceo is this his
ex-girlfriend or just like ex-partner
ex-partner co-ceo yeah I didn't know
there was two CEOs in a company well I
guess a news company so he ends up like
immediately just firing her out of
nowhere and she's like what the hell
like I don't even know what's happening
I thought we were doing great and then
he ends up coming out and saying like
well guys cuz she told me that this
other person said that I wasn't some
[ __ ] like some like I forgot what it was
but he was just like yeah so he she said
that he told all these employees about
me this one thing and so like she was
lying so I ended up firing her just and
that's like what so yeah it's [ __ ] a
headache
I love characters like this but the
apparently the company I last year it
may like 300 plus million oh and they've
expanded like crazy with social social
media though like you see all this [ __ ]
but then in like reality there's a lot
of crazy [ __ ] people on the top do
I'd make just a myth you gotta be that
crazy though the crazier you are the
more you have a bigger vision you can do
crazy [ __ ] you're not crazy enough David
Rock Korean more Korean yeah tours
several stores have shut down Estee
Lauder is taking them to court to remove
him from the board and limited his
authority and so they're just saying
there are a lot of these people that
follow this brand they're just panicking
because they love this product so much
and they're just trying to get their
hands on it before and I started make a
brand would you guys buy it we did
stupid nobody make makeup though oh I
don't you said a brand
oh no I'm gonna make a makeup brands
talk trash oh man bad Jeffrey star dude
has like a makeup he's like a makeup
mogul he makes like a hundred million or
whatever [ __ ] crazy I had no idea
[Music]